[Music]
like how am i sounding hey everybody
welcome to another edition how are you
my good man
nice to see you good to see you man
another day hotbox on house a so good an
awesome guest today
you know Mike people come in here our
guests come in here and I'm always it's
always amazing to see them with you
because you're such a legend yeah oh and
today I think our guest is of that same
ilk he's got that dragon's blood do you
do man Dale Earnhardt jr. everybody
thanks for coming though no I'm excited
about this man I was looking forward to
meeting Mike and being on the show so
I've been big fan his all all my life it
seems like man but it was a long time
yeah so it's uh it's gonna it's gonna be
fun let's do this I got a podcast of my
own so it's always fun to kind of come
on other people's podcast and see how
they do things and you guys got a great
setup thanks pal yo Jeff Gordon I used
to yeah yeah it was good guy he was fun
he was good he was hard to beat yeah so
I know a lot of people recognize Jeff
and he was kind of mainstream he was in
New York and LA sure yeah you're pretty
moonst recognizable name yeah my dad was
a big big deal and that's for sure so
that kind of got intimidated yes right
yeah dude I love that Mike Tyson knows
his nickname with the glasses on looking
at people yeah taking them out I love
that also in the studio we've got you're
one of your business partners yeah Mike
Davis Mike Davis hey guys good Hey all
right hey happiness and you co-host
deals podcast with them yeah we do the
Dale junior download everything l jr
download that's right yeah what do you
guys hit on that basically we'll talk a
little bit about the race or what
going on in the sport but otherwise we
have a lot of you know businesses and
things that we got going on we might
talk about that pop culture a little bit
of pop culture in there just because a
big fight from the weekend we'll talk
about that yeah so I'm a big Boston fan
so we'll talk about boxing if there's a
big fight or something like that
everyone smile sweet man
whatever the hell we want whatever
that's a great podcast and that's the
great thing I think people love podcasts
because it's a conversation it's a real
conversation for sure no it's not in
front of an audience or we almost don't
even think about the cameras being here
and they're not even doing anything as
far as we know yeah so it's you know you
can just have a real discussion I
totally agree man and I mean in this day
and age of you know ever moving faster
technology and social media and people
are constantly in their phones you know
our opportunities for this
person-to-person contact being able to
look guys in the eye and have a
conversation about [ __ ] that's really
going on it's very rare it is yeah it is
I think if podcast kind of gets back to
the roots of just that you know that
one-on-one conversation and obviously
also I think makes people comfortable to
where they will open up when we have a
guest on we have we typically get
content out of those guests in
conversation and things out of those
guests that they don't they don't feel
comfortable giving in other scenarios
and so that's great too you know do you
have children Dale I actually got a
little girl she's 6 months oh yeah so
that's new it's amazing that's why
there's a drive cars I don't care if she
I mean I I don't not want her to drive
other than the fact that it's very
expensive and I don't know if we could
probably invest our money in another
area she wanted to do something else but
she's gonna say hey I want to do X Y & Z
and we're gonna do it you know you're
gonna want to do you're gonna want it to
take them and do whatever they want to
do and just the fact that she wouldn't
want me to be involved in anything she's
doing it will be great yeah yeah no
doubt man
I have a little girl myself really
gonna be seven in December oh yeah
everybody says it goes fast luck it goes
yeah I'm sitting here at six months
though and I'm like me and Amy my wife
we're like come on come on you know we
can't wait for this we can't wait for
that I want to be able to what was it
like when y'all heard their voice like
for the you know you hear I'm cooling
and on but when they really get a voice
you know I heard cuz I stopped once they
get it yeah no doubt dude
no doubt but I remember well I listened
to your pod with Joe and you talked
about that yeah and I remember the first
time hearing my daughter's voice and I
was playing for the Bears at the time so
I was living in Chicago and my wife was
finishing up law school in San Francisco
with our my daughter at that point was
maybe two not even quite two years old
yet and we were living apart so I really
missed some of those stages but I
remember going to be with my wife and my
daughter during the bye week and the
first morning I was back I woke up and
my wife and my daughter were already up
and I could hear this little person's
voice and I couldn't believe that that
was my daughter talking yeah it was kind
it was really an incredible moment man
so now if you're in yeah you're in for a
treat just hearing you talk about it you
can tell how big a deal that is and
that's some that's one of the things
that we we can't wait we know we need to
be patient we know we don't need to rush
her along and and just enjoy it tells me
it's gonna happen ya know
no doubt about it man well you know
something that really struck me and I
never heard a guy like yourself you know
the caliber racer you are talk about
racing and to hear you talk about how
the car grips the road and how tight you
are to the road and that
first time you ran around the track when
your dad called you up it was like meet
me at the Raceway don't ask any
questions just be there and you're like
I don't know what's gonna happen I get
something I get to do this and you said
it was that first time you're coming
down that straightaway at like a hundred
ninety miles an hour and you're like how
in the [ __ ] am I gonna keep this car on
this on this road going into this turn
yeah I was looking at so you know I've
never been on a big bigger racetrack
than a half mile which is really a very
small track you're gonna run around 90
mile an hour there it's a smaller track
so I'm going to Talladega it's a two and
a half mile race track and I'm going
down the back straightaway for the first
time and I'm getting I'm getting up to
around a hundred and sixty hundred
seventeen hundred eighty mile an hour
and I'm just long back straightaway so
you're looking at the corner turn three
and it goes and arcs way off around the
corner and out of sight you know it just
seems so far away but you can look at it
and you're thinking how's the car gonna
stay in there how's the car not gonna
fly out of the track how is it gonna
grip like I've never felt this before
and I've never been in this situation
before to know that this is going to
work and so physics don't seem like that
you know the car would be kept in the
track and you when you go into the
corner and this is the force the
g-forces you kind of go down and to the
right into the seat and you sink into
the seat as you load into the corner and
then in the banking and that's when you
sense like wow this thing is grabbing
this track well it's like God got ahold
of this racetrack yeah and it's not let
go yeah and it's the most amazing
feeling so I bet man the best car you
drive no no well yeah the Mercedes I had
a Mercedes that used to be the pace car
for the f1 series that was a very
awesome car that's sweet but you know
it's uh I think I mean our race cars are
so setup to be able to get a hold of
that racetrack they got these giant
tires and they'll just get a hold of the
racetrack so well and they'll take the
corners extremely fast without it really
any
real concern but you push them to the
limit you know and sometimes you go over
that limit I bet you know it sounds Mike
have you ever driven a car 180 miles an
hour no no no what's the fastest you've
ever went Mike I don't know maybe 130
yeah that's fast enough that's pretty
fast
right that's pretty damn fast I mean I
feel like if I'm in a car going 90 I'm
going fast that's what's funny because
Mike's talking about going 130 miles an
hour on the highway pulled over by the
cops too I get nervous on the highway
going 130 on a racetrack and a crow in a
closed course in a car that's supposed
to be as safe as it can be to hundreds
not a concern it's weird
well driving a car on the highway though
yeah at a hundred thirty I'm like yes
don't know what's coming out and you got
this little strap you know you just race
car you harness the jet you know you're
you're tight-knit dancing so there's a
whole roll cage around here right right
new things built to protect you mentally
you believe that nothing can hurt you
sure and in a streetcar it's all the
opposite it's wild man so when you're
going that way because this is gonna
this is really where I want to go you
know with this conversation with you but
you're in this thing and you're going
200 miles an hour to and you are [ __ ]
you talk about how you're rattling
around I mean you're you know you get
into accidents you've flipped cars yeah
now with him when he knows the grab the
wheel those slowly rise yeah when the
car starts flipping if you don't grab
ahold of anything or something typically
obviously the wheels right in front you
so that's the easiest thing to get a
hold of but if you don't wrap the wheel
your arms kind of go out because the
centrifugal force is trying to throw you
trying to throw everything away you know
yeah and so your arms just start
flailing and you can see that happen in
crashes and so I learned that on the
street actually I flipped a pickup truck
and learned that my arms would do that
when the car started flipping so in a
race car I always was pretty cognizant
of grabbing that steering wheel when I
started to feel the car get light and go
up in the air Wow yeah to feel a 3,000
pound rate is that light that is the I
was never scared I was always thinking
in my mind no one ever I'm never going
to be able to explain this to somebody
that like I'm never going to be able to
tell somebody what this is like sure
what in what and that's it you can see
you feel the car is so damn heavy
but it's flying through the air and you
can't just you cannot describe it yeah
it's the weirdest thing it's crazy man I
can't even imagine and that's the
frustrating part I think about crashing
and all that is trying to tell it to
someone who's never wrecked a car race
you're in a race or anything it's sure
what do you compare it to what do you
dude do you get PTSD from that I don't
think so you know is it is it one of
those things like being a surfer
attacked by a shark you just got to get
back out in the waters thank you just
yeah I think once you get yeah you're so
I've had crashes and bad crashes and
when I go to that track or that corner
there's something in the back of your
mind that makes you concerned and you
don't perform well until you can succeed
go through that part of the track
successfully or go through that part of
the train without at crossing your mind
you know so I've done that before
I was racing a race and blew a tire and
hit the wall real hard at just one
racetrack and I ran a couple more races
there over the next couple weeks and
like my crew chief comes up to me and
says you're not going that corner the
same ever since she wrecked you seem to
be chopping the entry and trying to
avoid trouble and so I think that that
happens when you do have crashes or have
an accident at a crash or at a track you
kind of have a problem with that track
until you can go through there and do
well or do something well there that
makes sense I mean [ __ ] I've been in
little dingers and on the street and
that's good
maybe yes that no no man I don't know if
I need to drive anymore in LA that's a
bad thing
it's great it's bad there's no other
place like it so tell me this tell me
this what is the biggest championship
that you want it's your time to ride in
this particular championship you're
really thankful which one is that well
we got a championship race right now
happening I'm in the broadcast booth for
NBC and we're coming down to the last
two races of the year and we're going to
decide our champion for the Cup Series
in Homestead in two weeks and that's the
biggest that's the biggest award and and
biggest thing you can accomplish in our
sport in this car and I never won the
championship at the Cup level I want to
Xfinity Series championships which is
kind of like the college level of our
sport but as a broadcaster as a racer
for 20 years I kind of know what that
what that accomplishment means and how
prestigious that is and I can't wait for
a couple weeks to be at a crown or chip
suite that's exciting
so rattling around in this death race
that's you're in man what you you get
you deal with a lot of injuries yeah get
beat up oh yeah yeah
I broke I mean I broke my shoulder blade
you know I've had injuries like that
before but the worst I think for me has
been the concussions we write about it
in the book that we're I wrote a book
called racing to the finish and it's out
over there yeah and we talked about
basically the concussion experience that
I had from 2012 all the way up until
today and the mistakes I made the
crashes the reasons you know the
different moments in my career where I
had these problems and going to the
doctor getting the treatment my doctor
writes the foreword for the book my
doctor comes in behind a lot of the
things that we talked about in the book
and sort of gives a technical medical
explanation for what was going on in
this particular time in my career and
it's just a basically Mickey Collins is
my doctor in Pittsburgh he works with
the Steelers in the pain without
and he helped me twice he gave me my
life back to me you know twice when when
concussions
did you know made life miserable he
fixed the problems that I had and gave
me a good quality of life back and so I
feel like there's nothing I mean what
can I do to repay this guy for doing
that I mean what can I do so he tells me
that the best thing I can do is to be
open about my experience and that drives
people to him he says that two or three
people come in his office every week and
they you know asked him how do you find
out about us and he says two or three
people every week saved because if
something bill said in this article or
in this video and so writing this book
is a bit of a joint effort between me
and him to tell that whole story and
maybe even push me more people to make
better decisions in those situations
that I was in what types of treatments
did he use to help you recover because
you know I was telling you a little bit
about my own story before but I come
from the NFL I played six years as an
offensive lineman with the Jags and the
Bears suffered a handful of concussions
throughout my career you know and
concussions are a huge issue for
football players and you know the way
that those are dealt with in the league
is there there's not really you know you
talked about it a little bit you know
there's no treatment that the NFL or NFL
trainers doctors prescribe it's
basically a rest and recover type thing
you know in 2012 when I got hurt that
was basically it it was rest and
recovery no phones no electronics no
activity no going out to places doing
anything dis rest rest rest and shutdown
when I got hurt and he went back in 2016
that was scrapped it was exposure is
really kind of what they're about
pushing you into environments that are
going to stretch that muscle or come in
first yeah so he he was all about
exposure the same guy had changed his
entire approach in a short period of
time he's had some physical exercises I
had a lot of problems with my vestibular
system in my head
movement make me dizzy so I did a lot of
physical exercises just moving my head
too until they wouldn't create the
issues anymore wouldn't trigger the
symptoms anymore then he would give me
another batch of those I had some eye
problems with gaze stabilization when
I'd walk across the room the room would
bounce and he gave me I went to a I got
some computer programs what wearing
these funky glasses and would work on
these computer programs that would
really make my eyes work real hard to
hold 3d objects in 3d and stuff like
that just a bunch of stuff that was a
bit over my head but it really
physically made my eyes hurt doing those
exercises but it made my eyes stronger
to wear when I walked across the room an
object across the room did not move I
could look at it and hold it as target
watch a bird fly across the sky and
watch the whole you know watch it before
I couldn't I couldn't you know I just
couldn't stay on it yeah and I had mood
issues anxiety I took medicine for that
to suppress anxiety I don't you know
took that for probably a year and a half
and for the most part those those were
the that was the treatment that would
target the problems that I was having
and I took it took about three four
months before I started seeing progress
mm-hmm Wow yeah I had 12 concussions
from probably 2013 to 2016 and I hid
them from my wife hid them from my
family hid them from my doctor yeah hid
him from everyone in the sport and I
woke up one day and I just couldn't
balance myself well I hadn't crashed in
a month and I'd gotten up out of you
know I got up and out of bed and I'm
like man I can't I'm dizzy and my eyes
are something's wrong my eyes I can't
you know I didn't even know how to
describe it and they each day like
quickly in a matter like three or four
days it got worse and worse and worse to
where to walk out of this room I'd have
to hold onto this table and grab that
you know grab the door and it was
through door it was very bad I know you
you know I know you probably are you
know guys that have experienced those
type of symptoms and how do you win
yourself off the drugs the drugs were
very low doses
the very low dosage and I didn't really
appreciate taking them anyways as far as
just chemicals or or you know a drug is
not something I really enjoy doing but
what types of meds were you on I don't
really even know the name of it it was
just an anxiety suppression okay type of
drug there psych meds yeah and they
would make me completely not like
anxiety free it was incredible because
everyone walks around with a little
sliver of anxiety ago right and and I
was anxiety free for the first time in
my entire life and I was thinking this
is like the best version of myself that
I this is like the real potential that I
have is individual yeah and so I wanted
that but I didn't want to have to take
that pill to do it yeah and so ever
since then you know I've kind of you
know I've tried to manage my anxiety
just on my own but do you meditate you
know I don't meditate well no it's a big
that's really helped me man I bet it's a
big deal for me yeah you know something
else you know this is part of what we do
here is we educate about things like
cannabis and CBD you know we have a
little video that I'm going to play for
you in a second it's a was the Tyson
holistic summit that we put together as
a handful of NFL players MMA UFC guys
Mike was there of course some NHL
players all talking about how cannabis
and CBD has had a positive effect on our
healing you know dealing with things
like concussions and you know getting
off opiates and all that stuff you know
our federal government has a patent on
cannabinoids as neuroprotective sand
antioxidants so when you talk about
actual chemical compounds that can help
us deal with these types of injuries you
know we've got something here that's a
natural plant which is pretty
fascinating have you ever tried CBD I
have never tried it I was I was actually
reading about it a lot of it
probably three months me and my my wife
and I take ashwagandha and oh that's
groots though it is it is really good
and so I was reading about other you
know sort of alternatives with a condo
it's like a river entire Vedic route
that helps with all kinds of things it's
a it's an adaptogen so it helps your
body get into homeostasis helps your you
know tells you when you know different
hormones are needed etc keeps you
balanced it made me feel it made me it
it made me feel like I could handle
stressful situations with less anxiety
and when something that didn't really
need to sort of get under my skin
happened right didn't get under my skin
right you know and totally that was what
I was probably wanting the most from the
ashwagandha and that seems to be what
it's doing for me but ya know just me
have a bit of a energy that I like yeah
it gives you it sort of gives you this
vitality exactly yeah it's hard it's
very hard for me to put it into words
because it's not like coffee no caffeine
and it's not energizing like that but it
gives you this real this very
substantial energy there's no
satisfaction no that's great helps you
sleep but I was reading about CBD when I
was reading about ashwagandha cuz I was
you know obviously I'm gonna take this
stuff I want to know what it does yeah
and what the effects are to it and so
but I've heard good things
yeah very good things well check out
this video it's pretty quick but it's
cool it's got some there we go yeah here
we go
that's nice Los Angeles may 31st area
2018
Tyson holistic health & wellness suit
hosted by Evan Britton
hello everybody my name with Mike I've
been fighting over 20 years of my life
the injury started piling up first
injury I had was a concussion pretty
serious brain injury vertigo that was
starting to happen early on in my career
99% of the guys in the NFL locker room
are on highly toxic prescription drugs
tylenol at noon the advil at Florida I'm
not six benadryl xanax pain pills that
went to the doctor prescription pain
killers then I gotta hook them that send
me to rehab the downward spiral of you
know pharmaceuticals that left me retire
at the age of 28 tons and tons and tons
of drugs to treat individual problems
and we're not getting health care we're
not getting better
the opioid epidemic is just reaching
astronomical proportions as a physician
we need to learn we need to better
ourselves to better ourselves for our
patients
I was not never a cannabis user it just
wasn't my thing five months of bouncing
off the walls and pain and insomnia and
headaches and anxiety I just gave it
it's okay I'll try I'm a big fan of it
I'll stake my life on it then the great
equalizer to the pain in my life I've
been really dealing with a lot of pain
since my career and it really changed my
life then I realized also all the
information all the pain everything had
worked with everything for now I'm a big
advocate my first experience really is
with the the copper till I saw the CBD
and I've been using that you know
cannabis is a ten thousand year old
medicine for 70 plus years of propaganda
and misinformation that have stigmatized
and demonized this plant you know we're
really starting to unravel that through
science the endocannabinoid system is
activated upon brain entry
they whispers are over I think that if
medical marijuana is available when it's
up to be individual to doctor you tell
me it worked for you and work for others
it you know then we should find a way to
get that defined and made official and
then proceeded to educate in team Docs
and I think all of the weeds are now
appropriately focused on player
rehabilitation is eventuated planning
efficient this should be a part of that
conversation so now I think it's up to
the sports leagues to anticipate where
this is going maybe zero concussion
symptoms haven't looked back and he was
able to win a world title I have my life
back to cannabis and I probably wouldn't
be as filthy minded as I am today
my football career was the most
important thing to me I would not
jeopardize that brandy and I still use
cannabis because to me that that made me
a better football player speaking our
truth about what we've been through and
what cannabis can do as a medicine for
athletes I think it's time to take
ownership our own health move away from
the stigma move forward together and it
can really change healthcare in this
country and perhaps the world thanks so
much really kind of pleasure
those are pretty cool things absolutely
that's important work you guys are doing
man thanks man
yeah I appreciate that well I mean shoot
man is there anything I think we've had
a hell of a conversation yeah yeah I
really appreciate you coming man yeah
thanks Mike it's been great to hang out
and talk to you guys and certainly
appreciate the opportunity to come on
here talk about the book and and always
learning it's been educational for me
and and hope where you live at I live in
Charlotte North Carolina yeah came from
yesterday and the racist weekends in
Phoenix so that's where we'll be this
weekend okay and the broadcast booth and
look forward to it nice man you just
came that way to do broken and tasted a
little bitter yeah do a little bit of
book me in man you guys are helping me
out oh yeah man anything else you want
to say about the book yeah just racing
to the finish it's for sale wherever
books are sold
awesome yeah if you you know it it's got
kind of a couple different demographics
obviously someone who's ever had a
concussion there's be a great read if
you have somebody in your family or know
someone who's dealing with that
certainly it could teach you a lot about
what that person is dealing with and
obviously you know I think my fans you
know I retired a little early and they
had a lot of questions and I wasn't
forthcoming with all that information in
this rule spell that out to them that's
awesome man thank you thank you buddy
Mike another great one Mike thanks for
coming thank you guys you didn't talk
much Mike well you know what I just let
my man here do all the time it was his
experience but I could tell you this
Mike and I've been I mean you know the
things that we've learned about this and
I was living this experience with him we
couldn't understand what was really
going on and say because he was keeping
a lot of things secret and but in him
coming out and telling the stories the
one thing that's been very compelling
for all of us and I think that motivated
him was that all the people that were
not in racing necessarily but in other
sports or even not even in sports that
we realized that we're dealing with you
know some sort of head injuries or your
questions or whatever and so I think
that some of the stuff
that his doctor just been dealing with
you know they started out as the
athletes in Pittsburgh yeah now he's
seeing everybody I mean we've got
everywhere we go there's like you know
people going hey who's your doctor Dale
you know I've got a 16 year old girl
that had a softball injury or something
like that
and Mickey Collins is seeing them all
you know it's not just as professional
athletes but there have been other
professional athletes but so it's it
never been sort of the that's been sort
of the motivation and I think the thing
that made that book necessary and I
couldn't have predicted that when it was
happening I don't think he could have
either yeah you know what I'm saying
well I think it's you know it's such an
important message of you know how much
of an impact you can make when you speak
your truth yeah you know and you're
telling your story man who you are for a
guy like you to come out and share this
message you know it's it's [ __ ] huge
man and well I feel like I had to tell
the truth to be able to it for it to
make that impact that it make for
someone and yeah I just I hope it helps
somebody and I'm gonna be on this
conversation for the rest of my life you
know I'll be on this wagon for the rest
of my life trying to do whatever I can
to pay make him back and and give people
opportunities to see him it's awesome
well the podcast thanks for listening
guys we are out
[Music]